[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend gestern
startete die wie Israel sie nennt zweite
Phase des Militäreinsatzes heute folgte
direkt eine Mahnung aus den USA
Sicherheitsberater Jack Sullivan
appellierte zwischen Zivilisten und
Terroristen zu unterscheiden und auch
US-Präsident Biden drängte in einem
Gespräch mit Israels premier Netanyahu
darauf Zivilisten zu schützen eine
Forderung die im eng besiedelten
Gazastreifen wie wir ja auch in den
letzten Tagen schon sehen konnten
ziemlich schwer einzuhalten ist unter
anderem auch weil die Hamas die
Zivilbevölkerung weiterhin als
Schutzschilde benutzt was dieses Dilemma
für die Strategie des israelischen
Militärs bedeutet dazuleich ein Gespräch
mit einem ehemaligen us-gener zuvor
lückwalpot israelische Kampfverbände im
nördlichen Gazastreifen Bilder die die
Armee heute veröffentlichte es sei ein
Tunnel zerstört und zahlreiche
hamasterroristen getötet worden hieß es
Hamas bestätigte heftige Gefechte rund
um Gaza Stadt die Operation so die
israelische Armeeführung werde
schrittweise ausgeweitet
über Nacht haben wir die Zahl der
Einsatzkräfte im Gazastreifen erhöht sie
haben sich den bereits dort kämpfenden
Kräften
angeschlossen trotzdem schafft es Hamas
weiter Raketen auf Israel abzufeuern und
Israels Luftwaffe nimmt dem Gegenzug
Ziele in Gaza unterbeschuss die von
Hamas kontrollierte Gesundheitsbehörde
spricht von mehr als 8000 Toten seit
Beginn des Kriegs die Telefon und
Internetverbindungen konnten teilweise
wiederhergestellt werden aber die
Lebensumstände für die Zivilbevölkerung
verschlechtern sich zusehens das
Kinderhilfswerk uniceef warnt vor dem
Ausbruch von
Krankheiten das Wasser ist verschmutzt
und voller Insekten Wasserflaschen im
Supermarkt gibt es nicht mehr und wir
haben unhin kein Geld
mehr tausende Bewohner brachen gestern
in Lagerhallen des un-hilfswerks im
Gasastreifen ein um Lebensmittel und
Versorgungsgüter zu plündern die
öffentliche Ordnung breche zusammen
warnten die Vereinten
Nationen wir brauchen Wasser etwas zu
essen wir hungern hier es ist Gott
verboten was hier geschieht unsere
Kinder können vor Hunger nicht
schlafen das Rote Kreuz konnte heute
Medikamente aus Ägypten liefern Israel
kündigte an ab morgen mehr
Hilfslieferungen zu ermöglichen
Regierungschef Netanyahu war unterdessen
heute bemüht Nähe und Unterstützung für
die Armee zu demonstrieren gestern hatte
er in einem Tweet den
Sicherheitsbehörden des Landes
vorgeworfen ihn nicht vor dem
hamasangriff gewarnt zu haben es folgte
ein Sturm der Entrüstung netanahu musste
sich entschuldigen den Tweet löschen und
betonen er stehe voll und ganz hinter
den Sicherheitskräften am Abend nahm die
Armee erneut Ziele im Gazastreifen unter
Beschuss ein Sprecher rief die
palästinensischen Bewohner auf gazastadt
dringend Richtung Süden zu verlassen ein
Hinweis darauf dass die Kämpfe
ausgeweitet
werden über die militärische Strategie
und ihre eventuellen Folgen möchte ich
jetzt mit einem Generalleutnant ad
sprechen er leitete Einsätze in Irak und
Afghanistan er war Kommandeur der NATO
Landstreitkräfte in der Türkei und
zuletzt war ja
Oberkommandierender der US Army in
Europa Ben Hodges guten Abend good
evening good to have you PR ja vielen
Dank wenn Israel und das ist ja das Ziel
was die Streitkräfte und auch die
politische Führung ausgeruf h zerstören
gibt es dann überhaupt eine Alternative
zu dieser Bodenoffensive die wir ja
jetzt ganz offensichtlich
sehen ich glaube es wird sehr schwierig
sein für Israel diese Aufgabe Hamas zu
zerstören durchzuführen sei den sie
können Hamas von
erer
Unterstützung
isolieren und wenn sie nicht die grüe
geh warum Hamas inspiriert ist zu
kämpfen wenn sie das nicht tun können
dann können sie nur Infrastruktur
zerstören viele hammerskämpfer töten
aber ich glaube nicht dass sie sie
wirklich zerstören können das heißt das
was wir gerade sehen es heißt
offiziellen Phase 2 ist das dann
eventuell die falsche
Strategie ich denke aus innenpolitisch
Gründen muss die israelische Armee gegen
Hamas zurückschlagen wir nennen das
Abschreckung durch
Strafe so schickt man eine Botschaft an
Hamas und andere terroristische
Organisation das sind nicht einfach
israelische Zivilisten angreifen können
und ist eine politische Komponente sie
können nicht einfach das Problem in die
wü schicken dadurch dass sie Hamas töten
es muss ein Übereinkommen geben wo die
und wir sprechen natürlich über die zwei
staatenlösung da muss es eine gewisse
Hoffnung geben und man muss Hamas den
Grund nehmen zu kämpfen als ob es eine
zwei Staaten Lösung geben könnte es kann
keine rein militärische Lösung geben das
ist ja auch was viele kritisieren dass
es offensichtlich ein politisches Ziel
gibt aber im Grunde ein militärisches
Ziel aber eben kein politisches Ziel ihr
US-Präsident Joe Biden hat ja auch in
Richtung Israel gesagt während wir nach
9/1even Gerechtigkeit suchten und bekam
machten wir auch Fehler sehen Sie jetzt
eventuell Fehler in der Strategie oder
aber auch Fallen in die das israelische
Militär
hineintabt es gibt keinen Zweifel dass
Israel das Recht hat sich selbst zu
verteidigen und dieser Angriff von Hamas
ist nicht entschuldbar es gibt keine
Entschuldigung für das was Hamas
hunderten von israelischen Zivilisten
angetan hat aber trotzdem haben wir
einen Fehler gemacht nach dem 11
September unsere Entscheidung in den
Irak zu gehen hat nichts zu tun mit dem
Terroranschlag da gab es viele Emotionen
und wir sind nach Irak und Afghanistan
gegangen ohne richtig zu definieren was
unsere Strategie ist etwas was man
erreichen kann wir haben dann also
praktisch 20 Jahre lang versucht eine
Strategie zu finden die wir zuvor nie
wirklich definiert hatten auf jeden Fall
nichts erreichbares und der Präsident
versucht jetzt premier netanyaho zu
sagen sehen Sie zu dass die Emotion den
der Wunsch nach Rache nicht die
Strategie steuert es muss etwas
erreichbares sein etwas Nachhaltiges und
es muss eine Chance geben für einen
nachhaltigen Frieden wenn wir uns das
anschauen was gerade passiert im
gaserastreifen es ist sehr viel
Zerstörung in wie in wie weit kann man
denn die Verhältnismäßigkeit überhaupt
beachten ich hat es gerade schon gesagt
Joe Biden hat heute auch noch mal gesagt
ja das Recht zur Verteidigung haben sie
auch gerade gesagt hat Israel jetzt
greift es natürlich an auf seine Art und
Weise und Zivilisten kommen auch zu
Schaden kommt man aus diesem Dilemma
überhaupt
raus ich denke es wird unmöglich sein
Opfer unter der
Zivilbevölkerung zu vermeiden es wäre
naiv
zu glauben dass Israel das tun könnte
mein Präsident hat öffentlich ganz klar
gesagt und auch in direkten Gesprächen
mit der israelischen Regierung das
unsere Erwartung ist dass israelische
Soldaten
bewaffneten schießen in Übereinkommen
mit entsprechenden Abkommen und Hamas
benutzt natürlich die Zivilisten als als
Versteck und verstand sich dahinter aber
Israel wird dafür die Konsequenzen
tragen
und die Soldaten und die Kommandeure die
gehen jetzt immer tiefer nach Gasa rein
und sie haben natürlich eine Aufgabe zu
erledigen aber sie müssen sicherstellen
dass Sie keine
Zivilisten töten und das wird sehr sehr
schwierig sein und die Welt guckt
natürlich zu insbesondere die arabische
Welt schaut auch ganz genau hin viele
haben ja auch Angst wahrscheinlich nicht
ohne Grund vor einem Flächenbrand der
Sprecher der israelischen Armee hat kurz
nach dem 7 Tober gesagt wir werfen
hunderte Tonnen von Bomben auf Gasa der
Schwerpunkt liegt auf Zerstörung und
nicht auf Genauigkeit also vielleicht
auch da noch mal nachgefragt ist es
überhaupt möglich Zivilisten zu
schützen das wird sehr sehr
schwierig die Art und Weise wie die
israelischen Truppen jetzt nach Gaza
reingehen ist so
angelegt dass die Verluste unter den
eigenen sold reduziert
werden sie versuchen das methodisch zu
machen statt dass sie direkt in Masse
angreifen die Luftangriffe die
artillerieangriffe wo man Position der
Hamas beschießt diese Ziele kommen ja
vom Geheimdienst aber man kann natürlich
nicht wissen dass die auch Zivilisten im
gleichen Gebäude sind die Zerstörung der
Hermas ist ja das eine die andere Frage
die sich auch viele Stellen was ist mit
Konsequenzen gegen den Iran sie haben
schon gesagt sie sehen in im im im Iran
im Grunde eine Mitverantwortung dass der
Iran da auch seine Hände im Spiel hat
was bedeutet das also was müsste
eigentlich die Konsequenz daraus
sein natürlich der größte nutznäer ist
natürlich
Russland der engste Verbündete von
Russland ist der Iran nicht
China und die Entscheidung von Hamas
anzugreifen wurde sicherlich mit der
Unterstützung vom Iran durchgeführt und
auch mit Genehmigung des kremmels wie
weit sich das entwickelt wie viel mehr
der Iran jetzt macht das ist keine
Entscheidung die die selber treffen und
Hamas wir diese Entscheidung auch nicht
alleine treffen die Vereinigten Staaten
und Deutschland
alle von uns wollen sicherstellen dass
es keinen Flächenbrand gibt und dass die
hisbolla nicht auch noch mit
reinkommt und braucht einfach eine
breitere Antwort es geht nicht nur um
Israel wir müssen an Russland denken an
den Iran an Hamas all
diese Akteure sind Teil eines Ganzen
wenn wir der Ukraine helfen können
Russland zu besiegen wenn wir den Iran
abhalten können zu expandieren wenn wir
Israel helfen können Hamas zu
schlagen dann wenn wir unschuldige
Zivilisten schützen können dann schickt
das auch
das GZ das ist ein Schlüssel und an
ihrer letzten Antwort sehen wir wieder
vieles hängt einfach mit vielem zusammen
general Hodges vielen Dank für Ihren
Besuch
heute ich danke
Ihnen ja die
Bodenoffensive und ihre Folgen es kann
sie keiner wirklich verlässlich absehen
und daher stehen halt auch weiter viele
offene Fragen im Raum kann man die
Terrorgruppe Hamas wirklich auslöschen
wie viele Zivilisten auf Seiten der
Palästinenser werden dabei sterben wie
viele israelische Soldaten und
Soldatinnen und was passiert mit den
Geiseln in den Händen der Hamas kann man
diese durch eine Bodenoffensive wirklich
alle befreien selbst wenn Israel ha
genau wüsste wo sie sind die Drohung der
Hamas die Geiseln bei unangekündigten
luftanschlägen zu töten verhalt in den
Ohren der israelischen Zivilbevölkerung
nicht daher lehnt do eine Mehrheit der
Israelis die Bodenoffensive zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt ab so auch der Mann den Alisa
jung getroffen hat leor Peris Vater ist
in den Händen der
hamasim Peri wurde verschleppt aus dem
kibut
nios um 7 Uhr morgens hat er mir
geschrieben etwas Schreckliches passiert
hier das ist das letzte was ich von ihm
gehört
habe seine Frau versteckte Heim hinter
dem Sofa sie hat überlebt schreibt
seinem Sohn
sie habenim mitgenommen sein Sohn zeigt
mir Bilder von Heim der wie so viele der
Geiseln aus den kibuzim Friedensaktivist
ist Kinder aus Gaza von der Grenze in
israelische Krankenhäuser gebracht hat
die Kriege der Vergangenheit haben ihn
vor allem eins
gelehrt besonders als jemand der die
Kriege gesehen und verstanden hat dass
es so keine Zukunft gibt der einzige Weg
den es für ihn gab ist Frieden und auch
für ist die einzige lösungeden zwischen
Israel und Gaza obwohl die Hamas nicht
nur seinen Vater entführt sondern auch
seinen Halbbruder Danny und seine
Freundin im selben kibutz getötet hat
Danny reiste mit cararoline Bohl einer
seiner engsten Freundinnen aus
Deutschland durch Israel wollte ihr
seine Wurzeln zeigen die Woche im kibuz
war für sie der Himmel auf Erden
erzählte Caroline ihrer Mutter so nah am
Gazastreifen nur getrennt durch den Zaun
wusste sie die Sicherheit in Deutschland
sehr zu
schätzenol wurde 22 Danny 34 Jahre alt
lor Peri muss nicht nur mit diesem
Schmerz leben sondern auch mit der Sorge
dass durch die israelische Operation in
Gaza das Leben seines Vaters in noch
größerer Gefahr ist erst gegen die
Bodenoffensive der Fakt dass sie sich
selbst erlauben etwas anderes neben den
Geiseln zu machen ist für mich
unverständlich
fast jeden Tag gibt es nun Proteste in
Tel Aviv sie
rufen bringt sie jetzt nach Hause l
einzige
Gewissheit Frieden machst du mit Feinden
und du kannst dir deine Feinde nicht
aussuchen aber du kannst Frieden wählen
sagtor auch wenn er weiß der Wunsch
klingt naiv wie ein Kind wench diesem
sich nur ein paar Menschen für Frieden
wie sein vaterim einsetzen
[Musik]
über die Geiseln mittlerweile spricht
Israel von 239 Geiseln in den Händen der
Terrorgruppe Hamas will ich auch gleich
mit Michael beverunge sprechen schön
guten Abend Michael nach Tel Aviv
zunächst ganz kurz die Frage nach einem
Tweet des israelischen Regierungschefs
Netanyahu heute da deutete er an dass
die Sicherheitsbehörden das Risiko eines
Angriffs der Hamas unterschätzt hätten
und dass er nie vor kriegerischen
Absichten der Hamas gewarnt worden sei
mittlerweile ist dieser Tweet
verschwunden was hat es damit auf
sich Netanyahu kämpft schlicht um sein
politisches Überleben er ist der einzige
verantwortliche und wer wenn nicht er
wäre der Hauptverantwortliche in dieser
Sache der bisher noch keine
Verantwortung für das Versagen der
Sicherheitskräfte am 7 Oktober
übernommen hat wenn er das täte dann
müsste er wie alle andere wahrscheinlich
nach diesem Krieg zurücktreten darauf
hat ihn ein Journalist gestern Abend in
der Pressekonferenz angesprochen er ist
ausgewichen dann kam es zu diesem Tweet
wo er die Verantwortung auf Militär und
Geheimdienst abgeschoben hat breiteste
Empörung er musste den Tweet
zurückziehen er musste sich
entschuldigen seiner politischen
Demontage dürfte das nur weiter
beschleunigt haben unterdessen gehen ja
die Kämpfe in Gaza wir haben es auch
gerade gesehen weiter die israelische
Bevölkerung sieht die Phase 2 also die
diese verstärkten bodeneinsätze kritisch
insbesondere wegen der Geiseln wie geht
die Regierung mit dieser Kritik
um na ja es sind eben nicht verstärkte
bodenofens Bodenoperationen es ist eine
umfassende weitreichende vor allem auch
lang andauernde Bodenoffensive der Chef
des Generalstabs hat gestern noch mal
gesagt wenn man das Ziel hat die die
Hamas zu zerschlagen dann geht das nur
mit dieser Bodenoffensive damit hat sich
die Armee festgelegt die politische
Führung hat sich festgelegt und jetzt
muss sie das den Angehörigen der Geisen
erklären wie damit das Ziel der
Geiselbefreiung erfüllt werden soll das
eine ist dass die Führung sagt auch
Netanyahu gestern wir versuchen eben
militärischer Geiselbefreiung das zweite
ist wir versuchen militärischen Druck
auf die Hamas auszuüben weil sie dann
nur zu Verhandlung über die Geiseln
bereit sind ob diese Strategie aufgeht
das wird sich erst in nächsten Tagen
Wochen Monaten zeigen Michael bwerunge
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzungen wie
immer live aus Tel Aviv danke
sehr ja in Sachen Geiseln hatte der
türkische Präsident zunächst Angeboten
zwischen der israelischen Regierung und
der Terrorgruppe Hamas zu vermitteln ein
politischer Arm der Hamas sitzt nicht
nur in Qatar sondern halt auch in der
Türkei mittlerweile dürfte das für die
israelische Regierung wie hohnkling
nachdem Erdogan gestern gesagt hatte
dass Israel in der Region nur eine
Schachfigur sei die wenn der Tag komme
geopfert werde und mit Opfern kennt
Erdogan sich ganz gut aus sagen seine
Kritiker denn er opfere schon länger das
Erbe des großen Kemal Atatürk mehr noch
er drehe sogar die Errungenschaften
zurück die der Gründer der Türkei zur
Staatsgründung heute vor 100 Jahren
verfolgte westlich modern und sekular
sollte die Türkei sein doch davon ist
100 Jahre später nicht mehr ganz so viel
übrig den Anhängern Erdogan scheint das
egal zu sein sein Kritikern nicht Jörg
Brase Mehmed inji ist Bildhauer und
stolz auf die Republik mehmeds Verehrung
für Staatsgründer attürk ging seit dass
er seinen eigenen Sohn mustafha Kemal
nannte der 100 Jahrestag müsste
eigentlich ihr höchster Feiertag sein
doch Mehmed und seine Familie wollen
nicht z Recht in Stimmung
kommen wir sind in einerase in der die
en der Bürger eingeschrkt werden und
Stereotypen vorherrschen in Bildung und
Politik trotzdem verlieren wir die
Hofnung nicht und Glauben an die
Republik wir hoffen darauf dass es
wieder bessere Tage geben
wird der Skepsis kann der den Familie
Inge für die schlechte Lage
verantwortlich macht nicht so recht
nachvollziehen Präsident Reb TB Erdogan
und seine islamisch konservative
akpartei regieren das Land seit nun 21
Jahren eine Erfolgsgeschichte wie
Erdogan akribisch
auflistete
1923 betrug die Zahl der
Krankenhausbetten gerade mal 12000 2002
waren es 164 000 und heute sind es
000 Erdogan sieht sich als Hüter des
Erbes Atatürks wie der es damals gewollt
habe sei die Türkei bis heute Beschützer
der
Benachteiligten V Balkan in den Kaukasus
von Asien bis Afrika Turkmenistan bis
Palästina wo immer Menschen unterdrückt
werden und in Not sind altt ih die
Türkei zur Hilfe und hält ihre
Hand wegen des Krieges in Palästina
waren einige Programmpunkte der
Feierlichkeiten gestrichen worden so
waren dann viele enttäuscht dass dieser
große Tag kleiner ausfiel als sie es
erwartet
hatten ja klar in Palästina herrscht
Krieg aber wir feiern heute den 100
Gründungstag unser Republik das ist für
uns ein historischer Moment der sollte
nicht von einem Krieg überschattet
werden denn viele sind voller stolz auf
das was Mustafa kimal Attatürk vor 100
Jahren schuf eine parlamentarische
Demokratie das Wahlrecht für Frauen und
vor allem die Trennung von Staat und
Religion die Verehrung für Attatürk legt
Bildhauer m mit inje in jede Büste die
er formt seit Erdogan an der Macht sei
sagt in seien die Bestellungen in ihrem
Familien Betrieb von jah zu Jahr weniger
geworden ich versuche alles allein zu
machen Einkauf Verkauf Herstellung und
Lieferung ich weiß nicht wie lange ich
noch so weitermachen kann aber zumindest
hören wir nicht auf wir werden weiter
ums Überleben
kämpfen mit Atatürk Büsten sei in
Erdogans Türkei kein stat zu machen
sagen die Inis doch Erdogan Büsten nein
die würden sie niemals
bauen ist uns BU dahin dann ganz schnell
eine Frage nach der Rede heute was
unterscheidet denn den jetzigen
Präsidenten vom Gründer der Republik und
dessen
ideale na zu allererst natürlich die
Trennung von Staat und Religion
Präsident Erdogan versucht seit Jahren
die Türkei immer weiter zu islamisieren
ein anderer Punkt ist der dass seit
Zeiten Atatürks eigentlich die Militärs
immer die Hüter der Republik waren und
diese Militärs hat Präsident Erdogan
nach dem Putschversuch 2016 schrittweise
immer weiter entmachtet und dann hat er
eben die parlamentarische Demokratie
abgelöst durch ein Präsidialsystem das
heißt er hat auf dem Amt des Präsidenten
mehr Macht angehäuft als es in der
Verfassung Atatürks vorgesehen war jör
in den ersten Wochen nach dem Angriff
der Hamas auf Israel am 7 Oktober hatte
sich Erdogan erstmal zurückgehalten
warum jetzt die
kertwendee na er hatte sich ja angeboten
als Vermittler in diesem Konflikt aber
es ist nicht auf große Gegenliebe
gestoßen vor allem auf Seiten Israels
und da ist dann der Druck der
innenpolitische Druck auf Erdogan
gewachsen sich eindeutig zu erklären
sich eindeutig auf die Seite der
Palästinenser zu stellen das hat er dann
gestern bei dieser Großdemo in Istanbul
ja dann auch getan Präsident erdogan ist
ein Unterstützer der islamistischen
Muslimbruderschaft seine Partei seine
Koalition wird in großen Teilen getragen
von islamischen
Kräften und er hat auch immer selbst
erklärt dass er sich als Statthalter als
Verteidiger der Muslime der Welt sieht
das ist sozusagen seine staatsreson das
haben die Kemalisten ihm auch immer
wieder vorgeworfen dass die Türkei heute
eben nicht mehr nach den Prinzipien
Atatürks regiert wird nicht mehr nach
dem Prinzip der seäkularen Demokratie
sondern dass die Türkei an ihrem
hundertsten Geburtstag regiert wird von
einem politischen Islam sagt Jörg Brase
live aus Istanbul vielen
Dank ja und damit zurück nach
Deutschland auch heute gingen hier
zahlreiche Menschen auf die Straße um zu
protestieren in Berlin z.B unter anderem
gegen Antisemitismus und Islamismus mit
einem kleinen Überblick der
Demonstrationen weltweit im Grunde
beginnen deine Nachrichten Gundula in
mehreren deutschen Städten versammelten
sich Menschen zu Kundgebungen so
demonstrierten in München z.B viele
Solidarität mit Israel dagegen
beteiligten sich weltweit unzählige
Menschen wie hier in Madrid an
proalästinensischen Demonstrationen und
forderten eine Feuerpause in zahlreichen
Ländern der islamischen Welt auch im
Libanon gab es Proteste gegen
Israel im muslimisch geprägten Dagestan
im Nordkaukasus hat soeben eine
Menschenmenge einen Flughafen gestürmt
weil dort eine Maschine aus Tel Aviv
gelandet war dabei sollen antisemitische
Parolen gerufen und palästinensische
Flaggen geschwenkt worden sein Israel
forderte die russischen Behörden auf
seine Staatsbürger zu
schützen
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
hat vor kriegsgefahren in Europa gewarnt
an den Gedanken müsse man sich gewöhnen
sagte er in der zdfsendung Berlin direkt
die Bundeswehr müsse schnell
modernisiert werden deutschland müsse
kriegstüchtig werden und wehrhaft sein
in der Truppe sei der Mentalitätswechsel
bereits voll im Gang aber auch die
Gesellschaft müsse sich darauf
einstellen
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist im Rahmen
seiner dritten Afrikareise in Nigeria
eingetroffen dort wie dann auch in Ghana
geht es um Möglichkeiten die Migration
zu begrenzen sowie um eine stärkere
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit vor allem
im Energiebereich zusätzlich zu den
bestehenden Ölimporten soll Nigeria
künftig auch Erdgas liefern
sehä nach einem Treffen mit verbündeten
aus mehr als 60 Staaten sieht die
Ukraine eine zunehmende Unterstützung
für ihren eigenen Friedensplan Präsident
selenski lobte das bislang dritte
internationale Treffen als Zeichen der
Einheit gegen Russland zentrales Thema
war der von Kiev vorgelegte zehn
Punkteplan der unter anderem den Rückzug
russischer Truppen aus der gesamten
Ukraine auch aus den annektierten und
kontrollierten Gebieten
vorsieht einen Friedensplan zu haben ist
gut Frieden wäre
aber der ist zur Zeit ja leider nicht in
Sicht und so kämpfen viele ukrainische
Männer zumeist sind es ja Männer weiter
um den Aggressor Russland aufzuhalten
während nun mehr und mehr Frauen die
Arbeit übernehmen die vor dem Krieg eher
Männer inne hatten Dara Hassan Sade mit
seiner Reportage die ihn auch unter Tage
geführt hat wir sind in der Region
pnibro die Menschen in der Kleinstadt
Leben von der Kohle aus Sorge vor
russischen Luft sollen wir den Ort nicht
nennenxana arbeitet jetzt unter Tage
zuvor war die Choreografin aus bachmut
geflüchtet im Februar hat der Krieg
begonnen im Mai bin ich
weggegangen welcher Moment gab den
Ausschlag zur
Flucht Explosionen wie diese es gab jede
Nacht Bomben selbst Teile des
Bürgersteigs flogen in die Häuser jedes
Mal wenn ich mich auf dem Boden warf
sagte ich zu mir selbst ich halte das
nicht mehr
aus diese Explosion war ukrainische
Flugabwehr Ihr Einfamilienhaus in
bachmut steht nicht mehr ihr Mann und
ihr ältester Sohn sind als Soldaten im
Krieg gefallen diesen Frühling die
kohlemene ist nahezu der einzige
Arbeitgeber hier und Arbeitskräfte sind
gesucht viele Bergleute sind jetzt bei
der Armee ersetzt werden sie durch
Frauen bereits über 100 von ihnen
arbeiten in der
M die Frauen sind nicht nur stark sie
haben auch einen wirklich positiven
Einfluss auf die Bergmänner insbesondere
was das Arbeitsklima angeht das
Verhalten und die Kommunikation
untereinander die Frauen erzielen gute
Resultate wir sind auf dem Weg zu oxanas
Arbeitsplatz 480 m unter der Erde für
die Ukraine ist Kohle weiterhin
unverzichtbar zum Heizen zur Str
Gewinnung und der Winter kommt Oxana
beseitigt heute abgesetzten Kohlestaub
eine arbeitskchoreographie aus
schlichten monotonen Bewegungen 6
Stunden jeden
Tag ich konnte mir nicht einmal
vorstellen dass ich hier unten landen
werde ich habe im Ort meine Kindheit
verbracht meine Verwandten leben hier
mein Onkel war
Bergmann ich weiß wie hart die Arbeit
hier ist niemals hätte ich gedacht hier
zu
enden mehr als die Hälfte der Minen in
der Ukraine stehen still weil sie
getroffen oder von Russland besetzt
wurden diesen Produktionsausfall
versuchen Sie hier auszugleichen im
dreischichtsystem die bergfrauen wissen
um die Bedeutung ihrer Arbeit und wie
hart sie
ist natürlich möchte ich meine Arbeit
als choreogin Wied
aufehmen kreativen
Momenten und ich träume davon wieder
glücklich zu
leben ihr noch lebender Sohn der Kontakt
zu ihren ehemaligen Tanzschülern sagt un
soxana zum Abschied lasse ihre Hoffnung
nicht
schwinden und jetzt noch einmal
Nachrichten mit gundola und du beginnst
mit Sport Südafrika ist Rugby Rekord
Weltmeister in einem packenden Finale in
konnten sich die springbox gegen
Neuseeland durchsetzen Südafrika ging
schon früh in Führung die All Blacks
kämpften leidenschaftlich verloren aber
ihren Kapitän Sam Kane durch eine rote
Karte die erste in einem wmfale
überhaupt am Ende stand es 12 Z1 für
Südafrika der vierte Titel für das Land
und ein neuer
Rekord in der Fußballbundesliga hat
Bayer en am Abend mit einem 2:1 Sieg
gegen den SC Freiburg die
Tabellenführung wieder übernommen die
Breisgauer jetzt auf Tabellenplatz 8 und
in dem anderen Sonntagsspiel trennten
sich Eintracht Frankfurt und Borussia
Dortmund 3:3 Unentschieden Dortmund
damit auf Platz 4 der Tabelle und die
eintraff trcht auf
sie der
amerikanischkanadische Schauspieler
Matthew Perry ist im Alter von 54 Jahren
gestorben Hollywood die große
Fangemeinde der Kultserie friends
trauern 10 Jahre lang bis 2004 spielte
Perry den sarkastischen aber
liebenswerten Charakter Chandler Bing
unter anderem an der Seite von Jennifer
Aniston das brachte ihm eine Emy
Nominierung ein jahrelang kämpfte der
Star mit seiner Alkohol und
Tablettensucht warum gibt es überhaupt
Preise kann man sich ja fragen
Mitarbeiter des Monats die beste
Führungskraft des Jahres oder oder oder
es gibt sie tatsächlich in Hülle und
Fülle und auch in fast allen Branchen
und Bereichen fast immer geht es um
besonderes Engagement um besondere
Leistungen und beides trifft auf
Frederike Otto zu deshalb wurde die
klimaforscherin heute mit dem deutschen
Umweltpreis ausgezeichnet konkret für
ihre Untersuchungen zur Rolle des
globalen Klimawandels bei regionalen
extremwetterereignissen Hilke Petersen
es brennt überall in Südeuropa im Sommer
dieses Jahres ein Horror für Menschen
und Tiere die Flammen quälen und
töten das wütende Wetter will die
klimaforscherin Frederike Otto verstehen
sie und ihr Team versuchen
herauszufinden wie der Klimawandel
extremes Wetter noch verschärft was ist
das für ein Ereignis in der Welt in der
wir heute leben also in der Welt die
bereits 1,2° wärmer ist als zu
vorindustriellen Zeiten ist es z.B ein Z
jahresereignis oder ein H Jahr Ereignis
und wie wirkten Treibhausgase auf die
Hitzewelle in Südeuropa im Sommer 2 so
etwas können Frederico Ottos
Klimamodelle beschreiben sie simulieren
dann wie es gewesen wäre in einer Welt
ohne
Klimawandel bei dieser Hitzewelle haben
wir eben festgestellt dass dass es ohne
den Klimawandel ein solches eignis
eigentlich gar nicht geben würde
attributionsforschung heißt das
zuordnungswissenschaft sie folgen Spuren
und jedem Detail wie
Detektivarbeit am Anfang einer Studie da
haben wir halt na ja wenn man so will
Opfer also wir wir arbeiten ja wie
gesagt immer mit dem mit dem Roten Kreuz
zusammen und wir machen dann eine Studie
wenn eben viele Menschen betroffen sind
schon wenige Tage danach kann Frederike
Otto Erklärungen liefern und
pragmatische Fragen stellen gab es
frühwahensysteme wurden die
gehört welche Rolle spielte der Zustand
der Infrastruktur und so weiter und das
zeigt zum einen auf was alles schief
geht und erheblichen Einfluss darauf hat
wie viele Menschen in einer Hitzewelle
sterben auf die Liste der 100
einflussreichsten Persönlichkeiten auf
der Welt setzte das Magazin die in Kiel
geborene 41-Jährige klimaforscherin und
ihren Mitstreiter Frederik Otto findet
auch klimabewegungen haben die nötige
Aufmerksamkeit für dieohende Gefahr
geschaffen was mich extrem frustriert
ist wie mit jetzt in Deutschland der
letzten Generation oder hier in
Großbritannien just stop oil oder oder
eben diesen Bewegung umgegangen wird
dass die also wirklich kriminalisiert
werden obwohl deren Forderungen das sind
was die Regierung selber eigentlich sich
auferlegt haben indem sie das Pariser
Abkommen unterzeichnet haben der
Klimawandel ist da man kann ihn messen
und deshalb auch etwas dagegen tun sagt
die Optimistin Frederike
Otto und das Herbstwetter in der neuen
Woche wird klassisch regnerisch und
windig aber recht mild morgen vor allem
in einem Streifen von der Eifel bis nach
Brandenburg viele Wolken und Regen im
Südosten bei Föhn Sonne 11 bis 20° nach
einem regnerischen Dienstag ist es am
Mittwoch anfangs Freund später kommt mit
einem stürmischen Wind von Nordwesten
neuer Regen
auf muss der Hund drin bleiben so morgen
erwarten Sie hier Christian sieers und
Hanna Zimmermann zum heutejournal und um
025 Uhr gibt es hier wieder eine heute
Express machen sie es gut wo auch immer
Sie sind und einen schönen Wochenstart
[Musik]
tschüss